peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la guêpe au guépard en passant par le
père sang bleu et le poney ce sont là
avec un chinchilla vivant le voici
regardez le de près les bêtes que les
belles nous ont présenté au gala de la
belle et la bête le dixième une
tradition les bénéfices en aller comme
toujours à une oeuvre charitable
l'oeuvre des amis de la banlieue c'est
peut-être un peu tôt à moins que ce ne
soit un vison non c'est un renard
dussart qui fascine de futures belles
celui-ci visons méchant en cage la belle
est assouplie
pour un manteau il en faudrait 80 c'est
ce que pensent les photographes
[Musique]
la dame blonde à 2 erdene fauves comme
il se doit
[Musique]
mademoiselle de contades à un poney qui
lui appartient et qui la suit partout
un groupe de champions l'ouvrier à poils
longs
il y avait même une dame et sa licorne
tout au moins avant mauvaise la firme
sur la couverture du programme tapis de
velours pour le poney
[Musique]
bras de satin pour le scarabée sacré
sacrés vivant
[Musique]
enfin charme conjugués des belles et des
bêtes pour ce 10e gala
[Musique]